federal officials today will announce a
breakthrough in the fight against ms-13
hundreds of accused gang members and
associates are under arrest
the violent street gang is from El
Salvador but it's mayhem is spreading in
American neighborhoods first on CBS this
morning Margaret Brennan got rare access
to the crackdown was led by a unit of
ice known as Homeland Security
Investigations she went to one of the
deadliest battlegrounds that's Long
Island New York
Margaret is at the White House where the
Trump administration is watching closely
Margaret good morning good morning while
cracking down on undocumented immigrants
from Central America is part of the
Trump administration's strategy to stop
the growth of international gangs like
ms-13 operation matador is the name of
the joint law enforcement effort to
capture and deport suspected gang
members but so far there's been about
345 arrests since the month of May the
investigation revealed that he has
become a member of Amara South attention
as 13 Street gang the target of this
pre-dawn raid was a suspected member of
ms-13 who had illegally entered the u.s.
keep your head up and be safe out there
the team of 12 immigration agents and
local police expected the 20 year old
suspect to be armed may 10 now we got
four assistant Special Agent in Charge
Jason Molina he entered the country
illegally so and then he went through
the immigration process and a judge
ordered him removed but we know he's an
ms-13 member yes we have information
with pictures of them actually flashing
gang signs but gang membership is not a
crime and agents did not have a criminal
warrant so it appears that the two guns
are either pelicans BB guns no other
weapons were found but Molina's team was
still able to make the arrests based on
the suspects immigration status part of
the unique mandate of the Homeland
Security Investigations unit of ice an
hour later they nabbed a second suspect
he's a known ms-13 member he is an ms-13
associates so his known crime is
entering the country illegally correct
but that's it at this point that's all
you you definitely know that's correct
the purpose of classifying him as a gang
member or gang associate is because once
he goes in front of an immigration judge
we don't want him to get bail because
the whole point of this operation is to
get these known gang members off the
street both men were taken here to
alfonse d'amato federal courthouse with
plans to question and then deport them
the courthouse is also home to the
command center from Elena's team it's a
heat map which shows the locations where
the gang members are known to reside on
this residential street in nearby
Brentwood a man was found brutally
beaten to death last year there was a
killing right here and we believe that
was ms-13 that carried it out yeah a
month prior two teenage girls were
murdered a mile away
police suspect ms-13 gang members they
don't shoot people because it's too fast
and not painful they cut them up into
little pieces ms-13 are the equivalent
in their meanness to al-qaeda President
Trump has railed against ms-13
repeatedly since taking office they
kidnap they extort they rape and they
rob on Long Island he recognized the
work of Isis acting director Tom Holman
he's a tough guy he's a tough cookie you
felt your hands were tied in the past
absolutely Holman says that since
President Trump selection ice has been
able to make more arrests in part
because the administration allows him to
prioritize any individual who crosses
the border illegally not just those who
have committed other crimes the NGOs and
advocates can say what they want
everybody has her day in court
but immigration advocates complain that
this is simply a backdoor way to enforce
a heavy-handed immigration policy the
charges of racial profiling you flatly
deny people can make allegations all day
long I got twenty thousand American
patriots at work fries these are men and
women who do their job honorably they
get up every morning strap a gun to
their hip and leave the safety of their
homes and their families to protect
communities to protect people they'll
never meet and they'll never know now
Holman says the Trump administration's
message here is to undocumented
immigrants if you and your family make
it across the border you are not home
free now he says that hardline stance
has discouraged border crossings and led
to a decrease viana incredible access
Margaret that you should know that Gail
is worried as to whether or not you were
wearing a vest yes I won't you were our
cameraman our cameraman was wearing a
bulletproof vest when he got out of the
car good tonight I stayed in safer
territory still braver than most people
Margaret thank you